l'ambassadeur des états unis à à moscou
convoqué par les autorités russes
objectif lui présenter les preuves
irréfutables de violations commises par
les géants du numérique américains ont
fait le point avec notre correspondant
en train de carouge les autorités russes
disent avoir en leur possession des
preuves irréfutables de violation de la
loi russe par les géants du numérique
américain et ce dans le contexte des
élections législatives qui arrive dès la
fin de la semaine prochaine afin de
faire passer ce message l'ambassadeur
américain en poste à moscou a été
convoqué au ministère russe des affaires
étrangères j'ai lu trois versions de la
convocation de l'ambassadeur des états
unis au ministère russe des affaires
étrangères le ministère des affaires
étrangères a convoqué l'ambassadeur et
c'est le ministère des affaires
étrangères qui connaît la véritable
raison de cette convocation
il n'y a qu'une raison l'ingérence dans
les élections russes nous espérons que
c'est ainsi que les diplomates
américains ne rapporteront à washington
est pas comme l'ambassade des états unis
l'a expliqué dans un communiqué de
presse déconnectés de la réalité en
effet dans un communiqué de l'ambassade
américaine à moscou il est écrit que
john sullivan a rencontré le vice
ministre des affaires étrangères afin de
discuter de la proche de joe biden
concernant les relations russo
américaines bref quasiment une visite de
courtoisie bien loin de la version russe
des événements depuis le retour des
ambassadeurs dans leurs capitales
respectives
c'était à l'issue de la rencontre entre
joe biden et vladimir poutine au mois de
juin à genève eh bien le dialogue entre
les diplomates reste très tendue on
vient de le voir encore une fois mais ce
dialogue a au moins le mérite d'exister